- This is the 62nd annual Hume Lecture.
It's a great prestigious event each year.
The annual lecture in honor
of Dr. Edward H. Hume,
which is made possible by the generosity
of his family and many friends.
As you may know, Dr. Hume
devoted his long career
to working in China and elsewhere
in the cause of healthcare
and medical training.
He graduated from Yale
College back in 1897
and received a medical
degree four years later
from Johns Hopkins.
Dr. Hume worked in India from 1903 to 1905
before going to China,
where he founded the
Shanghai School of Medicine
and the Shanghai Hospital,
previously known as the
Shanghai Medical School.
Under the auspices of Yale
China Association in Changsha,
Dr. Hume also served as the president
of the Colleges of Yale
in China in the 1920s.
He returned to the United States,
but was recalled back to China in '34
and worked for several years
in health administration
in liaison with the Chinese
National Health Administration.
From 1937 until his retirement,
he directed the Christian Medical Council
for overseas work in New York City.
Shortly after his death in 1957,
funds from colleagues, friends, and family
enabled the establishment
of this lectureship
to bring to Yale eminent
scholars of East Asian studies.
And we have one such
eminent scholar here today
whom we're very pleased
and delighted to welcome.
Professor Nicolas Standaert
is professor of Sinolgy
at KU Leuven in Belgium
and a member of the Royal Academy
of Sciences and Arts of Belgium.
He took his PhD from
Leiden University in 1984,
and has spent the years since then
teaching mainly in Flemish
and Dutch speaking countries
with the occasional foray
into China and North America.
Professor Standaert has
produced a decade of monographs,
numerous co-written or co-edited volumes,
and he's made great
contributions to the field, also,
with volumes like "The Handbook
of Christianity in China."
Those two thick volumes that sit
in all of our research libraries.
His own major research
focus is cultural contacts
between China and Europe in the
17th and the 18th centuries.
His work is on the history
of books, people, and ideas
that crossed between China and Europe.
He writes and reads extraordinarily well
on both sides of that divide.
So a work like his "Chinese
Voices in the Rites Controversy"
analyzes the Chinese end of
a story that we often hear
from European perspectives.
While his latest book,
"The Chinese Gazette in European Sources:
Join in the Global Public in the Early
and Mid-Qing Dynasty,"
looks from the opposite
end of the viewfinder
at European reception.
The arc of his work
began with Yang Tingyun,
thinking about his influence on...
The influence of Confucian
and Buddhist ideas
on Christian thinking in that
period in the 17th century.
Then, he worked through works
on a particular object or book,
and more recently multiple
projects on rituality,
visual culture, historiography,
and print culture.
His books are exquisitely produced.
For example, "The Chinese Voices
in the Rights Controversy"
has a whole series of
wonderful reproductions
of Chinese texts in color,
and some of them fold out in full form.
Both in keeping with
his research interests
and also, I suspect, by being a Jesuit
and having access to nice presses.
We were discussing at
work, at lunchtime, today,
his work on "L'autre dans la mission,"
after (speaks French).
Again, how dance is a moral
national interest in China,
in early China,
and how the pauses and the silences
are ritually important too.
And again, you can see all
these wonderful illustrations
of dance figures throughout the work.
Professor Standaert has not
only given great service
to the field in his books,
but also in other aspects.
He curates the EU China list, email list,
that many of us receive
details every few days
of new articles and new
books produced in this field.
He's also been a curriculum innovator,
creating service courses
throughout Belgium.
So super delighted to have
you here speaking to us today,
and we're looking forward to your lecture
on "The Interconnected
History of the Chinese Gazette
in the 18th Century." Welcome.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you very much for
this very kind introduction.
I'm delighted to be here
and very honored also to be here.
I also thank the foundation
to support this visit
and also the center to welcome me.
I'm coming from a food
culture and a gift culture,
so I also brought chocolate Easter eggs.
So during the break at the end,
you can take them and make sure
that at the end of the
reception, nothing is left over.
I'm not going to carry them home.
Let me immediately start with
the talk, looking at China
from the periphery...
"The Interconnected
History of Chinese Gazette
in the 18th Century."
And I first start with
a bit a personal note.
You already referred to it.
So my main interest in research
is this very simple question,
"What happens when two
cultures meet each other?"
When I was taking my
Sinology classes in Leiden,
I had some courses in anthropology,
and that was all about
contact between cultures.
That was a specialty also in Leiden.
And I was fascinated by that topic.
And I also had the chance to have
Eric Zurcher as a professor.
Eric Zurcher, who was also
the Hume lecturer in 2003.
So that's more than 20 years ago.
And Professor Zurcher
is known for his studies
on Buddhism in China,
but also on Christianity in China.
Basically, he had two
books and 60 articles,
and half of them are on Buddhism
and half on Christianity.
And his major question was,
"What happens when
Buddhism arrived in China,
and how was it transformed
by Chinese society?"
Though the title does not
really sound like that,
"The Buddhist Conquest of China."
In fact, he was approaching the question
from the other side.
And having studied that subject,
he was wondering what happened
with another "minority"
religion, like Christianity
in China, in the 17th century.
So I attended his seminar,
and then he encouraged
me to pursue that topic.
So that's a bit of the
origin of my research.
And in one of the interviews he gave,
people asked him, "But, why?
Why do you study this question
and also Christianity in China?"
And he answered, "I believe
that Chinese culture
shows its futures most clearly
when it is confronted with
something from outside.
It's like people in conflict.
When you are quarreling
with your neighbor,
you may see things and show things
about your character
that you otherwise never would.
In the same way, the Chinese have shown
certain characteristic features
in their reactions to
Buddhism and Christianity."
So his major, yeah, concern was, yeah,
"I want to understand
China as a sinologist."
And that's also my primary interest
through an inter-contact between cultures.
And to give my, yeah...
To put that in a larger context,
because I put as a title,
looking at China from the periphery,
I think about 10 years ago,
we made a major invention
in the photography history
because we invented the selfie.
And by inventing the selfie,
we created the illusion
that we no longer need
something that was
essential for photography.
Namely that it was always the other
who made a picture of myself.
And now we think that when we
take a picture of ourselves,
we only need ourselves.
And that's a kind of challenge,
I think, for history.
How can that relate to
the sentence of Turk also?
How can maybe... It's not the only way,
but how can also how, like,
looks or how, like, sources,
tell something about China?
And this is related to
a concept of interaction
on which, yeah, I'm doing
further research at this moment.
I just do small,
let's say theoretical break,
on this in-betweenness.
So if you would ask me,
"What is my vision on
intercultural history at..."
And I take the case of
the 17th, 18th century.
To put it very general,
you have the Chinese,
you have the Europeans,
and they interact.
And then there is a kind of
text, (speaks foreign language)
the mathematics and we wonder,
"Is this now Chinese? Is this European?"
Whereas what I am interested
in is that, in fact,
this is an
result of an interaction
and an in-betweenness,
and any in-betweenness
can lead to a story.
Just like in this meeting, we meet.
This is a kind of interaction.
And after that, at the reception,
you can start to tell a
story or your question,
and you send an email to someone,
or I will tell something to others,
"How was it?" And so on.
It's always a story.
And this is, or can be, expressed
in new cultural creations,
such as text, images,
artifacts, buildings,
but also in rituals,
communities, concepts.
Now, as historians,
we have access to these
cultural creations.
And to a certain extent,
maybe our dream is also to get some sense
through the story of the
original in-betweenness
or the interaction that took place.
But it's even more important
is that the same interaction
is also between our documents
and the way how we look at them.
So this is a little bit the
frame in which I try to reflect,
but now I will only focus
on two aspects of it.
Namely first, looking at the
culture from the periphery.
This is nothing original, I think.
For instance, at Fudan University,
you have this institute
for higher advanced humanistic studies.
And that's one also of the teams.
(speaks foreign language)
So on the basis of written
material, other views,
what is said about Chinese
history, for instance.
And the whole idea expressed
by several scholars,
also here at the university here,
about interconnected cultural history.
So what will be my case?
My case will be the Chinese gazette.
And as you can see, this is a drawing
of a photograph, not...
But a drawing by an Italian,
who made the drawing of
this grand counselor.
And this is the only image
that is still preserved.
And you can see here's the other
who makes the picture of this person.
So this latest book also to involve
a little bit my personal history.
I have a project on print
in 17th and 18th century,
because when the missionaries
arrived in China,
unlike in Latin America, in India,
in the Philippines, and so on,
there was an active
printing culture in China.
And not only Matteo Ricci says that it
is cheaper, faster, and more
efficient than in Europe,
but there was no pre-printing censorship.
So they immediately could
publish what they wanted.
Within this context, I was
raising the simple question,
"Did the missionaries
also read the gazette?"
I come back on the gazette,
the official newspaper
with official decisions.
And I had hoped to spend maybe two weeks
on this topic because I said,
"Well, there will be not
so much material about it."
And I spent three years on it.
So this was a kind of serendipity.
And then Covid came,
so I had the occasion to work
a bit harder to produce a book.
And this Covid also affected one of...
Moriga who is sitting there,
because she had the scholarship for Yale,
and she could not leave for Yale.
And now she's here.
But her state was delighted.
And when she told her that, I said,
"Well, you come and work for
me and you will help me."
And so this book is also
partly with great help
of Moriga by criticizing my text.
So we... I will focus on this gazette.
And what is a gazette?
"It is a publicly available
government gazette
that was distributed and sold in print,
and sometimes also manuscripts."
And generally, it is called
"dibao" or "chaobao,"
or sometimes also "jingbao."
Or let's say in Western literature,
it's most often known as jingbao,
the Peking gazette.
Now, since the 90s,
there have been a number of
publications on this topic,
mainly also by Chinese scholars.
You find here the references.
And Morcrose, in one of her
articles, she mentions...
Or in a dissertation, she mentions
there are three ways in
which the gazette is studied:
history of the press,
or history of the state,
or history of the information in China.
And here are three examples
of these approaches.
Barbara Mittler
treated this topic among her work
in the context of a newspaper.
And so then, you'll
link it to a newspaper.
Hilda De Weerdt on the
distribution of information
in the Soong Dynasty.
And Emily Mokros has recently this book
where the link with the state is made.
And for the period after 1800,
the information is quite extensive.
Also in English,
because quite a number of missionaries
translated these Chinese
jingbao into English.
And there is a whole
database on it by Brill.
And also the reader that
is published also by Brill.
Now, what is the problem?
The problem is that hardly
any Chinese gazettes
are preserved from before 1800.
Basically, for instance,
for the Qianlong period,
in that 60 years, you
only have 394 gazettes,
which means 394 days,
which means, more or less,
one year and a half of text.
So to compare that with Europe,
where the newspapers, or
what we call newspapers,
existed since the end of the 16th...
In fact, the early 17th century.
Since the 1720s, yeah,
you have quite a extensive
documentation versions
of gazettes of the late
17th century and so on.
Here you have also from
the Yongzheng period,
and that's called dibao,
but that is, in fact,
not an original gazette.
And it's the title that
is used later to put it
and to make it as a reference,
but it's not an original text.
So what is then the next problem?
It's that most scholars will use the name,
"jingbao, Peking Gazette,"
and also the structure is one
of the gazette after
1800 for what is before.
One solution is to check
for references in Chinese.
Diaries, notebooks, and novels.
As for instance, Hilda De Weerdt has done
with other people as well.
So my simple question was then,
"Can we find some references
about the pre-1800
gazette in this periphery,
namely in European,
or as I will refer to, in Korean sources?"
This was not completely new
because there are two other scholars
who briefly have done some research that,
especially NII Yoko for the
Amyu Period.
So what will be my basic
statement during this talk?
So regarding looking at the
culture from the periphery,
I will try to convince you that, indeed,
European sources expand our knowledge
on the gazette before 1800
and disregarding to the structure
of the content and so on.
And moreover, that they inform us about
how Europeans read the gazette,
and also as global agents
informed Europe about the gazette.
And then the next step will be
a kind of interconnected history,
namely that if we looked and used
all kind of digital databases,
we can discover how
these translated versions
of the gazette also were
received, for instance,
by enlightenment thinkers and developed...
Helped to develop the thought
about not only about China,
but about European politics.
So that will be my major statement.
Now, I had to solve a first problem.
Namely when I saw translations
or quotations from the gazette
was to verify whether
these were correct statements.
Was this invented by the missionaries,
or was this really...
Can that be found in a gazette?
So you have the gazette,
and then you have the Western manuscript,
and then you have the printed text.
But the problem is that these gazettes,
except for eight copies,
are no longer preserved.
So what did I do?
I took a sideway,
and I first tried to find the
references in the Shalu.
But the Shalu is not the
origin of the gazette
because the Shalu was often compared
later than the gazette was.
Let's say it was printed within...
Or distributed within a month after
the event took place in the palace.
So, but on the basis of the Shalu,
I could identify the same passages
in the (speaks mandarin) or
in the (speaks mandarin).
the edicts by the emperor.
And they were a much
closer, reliable source
to what was taken over in the gazette.
Because what happened at court,
the decisions were then written
and then put on a board.
And then people copied them,
and then they were printed.
So to make this concrete,
this is a manuscript.
And there you will see...
I can't see what we here.
The text here and there. It's
written (speaks Mandarin)
Whatever, (speaks Mandarin)
So I see this figure,
and then I try to find in the academia,
the Scripta Sinica database in the Shalu,
if I can identify that.
And indeed, here you
have this figure here,
and I can identify this name
in the French transcription
of the 17th or the 18th century and so on.
And then on the basis of this,
this is the (speaks Mandarin)
and these are the original edicts.
And the same here with the passage
about Russian and the famous question.
And I could identify the sources.
So just like the collection
in Brill for the post-1800,
and the reader, so Brill asked
me to include it in my book.
I have about 60 pages identifying
more than 300 items of...
That were translated
in one or another text
in European text.
And that can be linked to original events
that you always can check.
So what I shall do now, in my book,
I discuss the country
period, the Yongzheng Period,
and then the Qianlong Period.
I will focus on the Yongzheng period,
which is most interesting
in terms of the interaction.
And let us start with the production,
the printed sources.
What are the most
important printed sources?
The first appears in the "Lettres
Edifiantes Et Curieuses,"
which is a major collection in Europe
in the 18th century with 34 volumes.
And in it, you can find
three letters in total,
more than 300 pages by a certain
missionary, Cyr Contancin.
He's not known at all.
He has no text in Chinese.
He hardly had any other Lettres.
But he has these three Lettres
that are completely
devoted to the gazette.
And he arrived in China in 1701,
spent seven years in Beijing,
and then he was an exile in Canton,
and that's where he did the work.
He came back to Europe.
He worked with Du Halde on
"Description... de la Chine."
And then he left back to
China, but he died on the way.
Now in this text, he gives
information about the
content of the gazette.
And he says, "Well, you have
the names of the officials,
criminal cases, admonitions,
rituals, laws, and so on."
When you look at this list,
and you compare that with
descriptions today in Chinese
or in Western sources about the gazette,
it's very, very similar.
And so yeah, the good understanding
of what was the gazette.
And I did the same work.
I come back on this text later,
which of course is Lettres.
And you can see here, again, the case.
This is a (speaks Mandarin)
but that's the French translation...
Transcription in the 17th century.
To give an example of
what kind of events is
translated and reported,
here you have an overview.
"The mourning and installation
of the new empress,
a memorial archway,
the rescue of people in
years of bad harvest,
the relief of the poor,
death sentence," and so on.
So as you can see,
these topics are not
related to Christianity.
And in the 300 pages,
he hardly has any references
to Christianity in an explicit way.
Next, he gives information
about the structure
and the form of the...
Of the gazette.
And here you can see, the memorials,
the answers by the emperor,
the instructions of the emperor,
other memorials as well.
And he also adds that they contain more
60 to 70 pages.
That's a little bit of a problem,
but that can be solved
in one way or another.
Do we have a gazette of
the Yongzheng period?
Well this is, in my eyes,
the only copy that is left,
or that I could identify.
And this can be found in the
Osterreichische
Nationalbibliothek in Vienna.
And as you can see, the
title is "Tizou Quanlu."
You find it here.
And you have the structure of the gazette,
and then first decisions
here and then it continues.
You have the different departments.
So this has the whole structure.
Now...
Why is this probably the only copy left?
And moreover, is this the name
of the gazette at the time?
I checked in plenty of
databases on "Tizou Quanlu,"
and I could not find any
reference in a Chinese database.
Only in Korean databases.
In Korean databases of
this (speaks Mandarin)
These are the reports of the delegations
that annually from Korea went to China.
And there you have reports and
quotations from the gazette.
And they said, "Oh, today
we read this and this
in the 'Tizou Quanlu.'"
Moreover, they add in one of the sections,
"And this is the same as our chaobao"
So they really make this link.
Maybe we have a second copy left,
and that's in this box here.
So that's in the museum in...
Museum national d'histoire
naturelle in Paris.
And they have a collection
of stones and of
mineral collection.
And most probably these
minerals are wrapped
in paper from the gazette.
I already asked them,
"Yeah, could we open it?"
But they still have to discuss that.
But I have to convince them,
because they may have the second copy
of gazette in the world. So...
Now, so you wonder, "Yeah,
but this is not Chengbao...
Or this is not (speaks Mandarin)"
So there was already a very
important article in '92
in Wen Wu by Pan Tien Shen,
saying that, "Yeah, we are always using
this term (speaks Mandarin),
but (speaks Mandarin)
is only used since 1852
with a few exceptions before."
And the term used in the Qianlong period
is the (speaks Mandarin).
That's this here.
And here you have some copies
of the (speaks Mandarin)
that are preserved in Paris,
and of which know that Amyu...
He used it in here.
You have the handwriting
of Amyu in the top.
So what is the conclusion then?
Provisional conclusion of
this research is that, yeah,
the identification of this
text, of the "Tizou Quanlu,"
that this is kind of forerunner
of the (speaks Mandarin),
which later then became
the (speaks Mandarin).
And this is one of the examples how
by looking from the periphery,
you can discover something
about Chinese sources.
You also know this text because here
in Yale there is this project,
in which I don't know whether you look...
I don't know.
See we... But anyway.
So you have the references to it.
And it was also thanks to Martin Heijdra
with whom I was in contact.
That he made me attentive
to the (speaks Mandarin)
and so that I also
discovered them in Paris.
So we go back to Contancin.
He also tells something about
the significance of the gazette.
So, and this is a team that
will come back and back.
He said, "They are very useful.
Instead of filling it,
as is done in certain parts of Europe,
with useless things and
slander and calumny.
In China, it only mentioned
what relates to the emperor."
In Europe, we have newspapers with gossip.
But in China, this is reliable material.
And that's why it can
also be an instruction
for literati and the People.
And then he adds the following.
I will read the whole sentence
because it's important
for what we'll follow.
"Nothing is printed here
which has not been presented
to the Emperor, or which does not come
from the Emperor himself.
Those who take care of it,
would not dare to add anything to it,
not even their own reflections,
under the penalty of corporal punishment.
Last year, two writers
were sentenced to death
for having inserted in the Gazette
some circumstances which were false."
So this is only one
sentence in this 300 pages,
and I spent a lot of time to know
whether that was correct or not.
Finally, I found the reference,
and indeed there was a case,
that is mentioned also in the Shalu,
where the Emperor had a meeting
with some of his counselors.
And afterwards, they went out on a boat
in the summer palace,
and they got drink,
and they were drinking wine and whatever,
and they had a good feast.
And two of them, two of these reporters,
in the xiaobao probably, mention...
Mention what happened.
And then the Emperor
said, "No, it's not true
because I never drink wine." And...
They were condemned to death.
So we know that this was a real case also.
There are also some
personal considerations
throughout the concern in the gazette.
It's useful to a missionary,
and he regrets that for years.
"I did not treat the newspaper.
And now when I'm in the South,
I see how interesting it is
for religion and laws and
customs and language."
And most of the missionaries don't do so
because the language is not enough.
Or they immediately, the idea of...
Associate the idea of gazette
with a European gazette.
They imagine that it...
In which one puts or has
put everything one wants,
good or bad, without any distinction.
And you see their view
on European gazettes
in contrast with China.
So this is a first source, 300 pages.
(speaks French)
Second source is Perroni,
and that is a person for...
Who was procreator of "Propaganda Fide."
And he was also, at the
same time, in Canton.
So probably they also even work together.
And he sends a yearly report to Rome
for the "Propaganda Fide,"
and one finds them in the
archives of the "Propaganda Fide."
What is interesting here is
that we have a transcript
of the whole text in Chinese.
That's really unique, on which we can...
We don't have the original gazette,
but we have the transcript.
The content, the form, is
very similar to Constancin.
The difference, you can say, is that
Constancin addresses it to Du Halde
to be widely spread.
Perroni is only for the "Propaganda Fide."
It was not published at all.
What is unique is the
presence of this Chinese text.
He also has some personal considerations,
and what do you find?
Yeah, the same references
nor is there any danger
that the story will be altered
by a passion of the writer.
And that happened... That someone was...
Two people were condemned for it.
Now...
Both of them, they mainly translate,
but in between, one will
find some references
with their idea on the emperor
and about the bureaucratic system.
So this is not a major topic.
Maybe for the first letter
it is, but not in the other.
But it transpires, and
between the translations,
one will find some few
sentences discussing that.
Now, what is the general idea of Contancin
regarding the emperor?
So despite the fact that
Christianity is persecuted
and that he, himself, is in exile,
it's a rather laudatory
description of the emperor.
He has a wise government,
service to the public utility.
He uses really this public utility,
which was a team also in France.
An active bureaucracy and...
With officials taking initiative.
Important to underscore that
not all the other Jesuits
had the same opinion,
because Gaubil and Du Halde,
they were much more critical.
They considerate it despotic government
and an absolute and feared master.
I come back on that topic later.
Perroni has a (speaks foreign language)
because on the one hand,
he is positive the emperor
is good at lecturing,
he is attentive to the
needs of the people.
There is a bureaucracy
that has good communication
with him and so on.
On the other hand, he expresses the idea
that the emperor is
blinded by his officials.
His speeches are
disconnected from reality.
The bureaucracy is perpetually flattering
and praising the emperor.
So what do we learn from
this production, you can say?
Well that we already learned
something about the gazette,
the existence of the gazette,
the form of the gazette,
the extent of it, but also
something about the content
that is represented in this text.
So that's the first
point I wanted to make.
This is the presentation.
Let us now look at how were
these text, this information,
how was that distributed
before looking at the reception
by the enlightenment thinkers?
Distribution in the first
place by academic journals.
So at that time in France, for instance,
there were quite a number
of academic journals.
And what is typical for
these academic journals,
let's say academic or
intellectual or the republic,
the letter, is that
they have book reviews.
But the book reviews are
not, in the first place,
a whole evaluation of a book,
but rather consists of very
large excerpts of the text.
And that's important because
they discussed the text by...
Or let's say they present
the text by Contancin.
And for people who did not have access
to "Lettres Edifiantes Et Curieuses."
In fact, the information of the...
About the gazette three times.
Because there were three different volumes
over a period of nearly seven, eight years
were produced in, for instance,
"Journal des scavans" of
"Memoires de Trevoux."
And one find in them the
same vision, the content,
the difference with European gazettes
and the vision on the emperor.
You also have the
newspapers, or the pamphlets.
For instance here, "The Bee Revived,"
which is a kind of pamphlet
that was only published
during two or three years,
based on the text that we
will see in a few minutes.
And in which there is a whole description.
The public gazette
is the reverse of our European gazettes,
which are medley of truth and falsehood.
You see that these points are repeated.
And the reference, again,
to these two writers
that were content.
So these are newspapers,
journals, also some books.
"Description... de la Chine"
is an important production.
Four volumes edited by Du Halde,
and was edited twice in French,
in France and in the Netherlands,
in English, in German,
later also in Russian.
And in it, one finds, again,
a description of the gazette.
"There is nothing inserted in the gazette,
but what has reference to the government."
It's to direct and to instruct
the Mandarins and the people.
And again, the reference in 1725,
you had these authors who were...
Writers who were condemned to death
because they spread false information.
We can look even further. You have...
Works on Chinese and world history.
One of them is De Mailla,
"Histoire generale de la Chine."
It's a remarkable work.
More than 7,000 pages, 13 volumes.
This is, until today, still
the most extensive work
in any European language based on Chinese
and Manchu sources written by one author.
We have, of course, "The
Cambridge History of China."
150 authors.
I'm not sure that it
already has 13 volumes.
But these are nearly translations,
or basically translations, of
the (speaks foreign language),
in the Manchu version basically.
And in it, it is...
Includes also the Yongzheng period
of which was not yet written
the history in the
classical Chinese history.
So they took all the information
from the letters of Contancin
to write that part of history.
And other works, like de Marsy,
"Histoire moderne des
Chinois, des Japonnois,
des Persan," etc.
in which you also have a whole chapter,
or whole part, on the gazettes.
So this is the distribution.
What could we say about it?
First, I drawn the idea
of Jurgen Osterhammel,
this famous book in favoring the East.
We can state, or I can state,
that Europe was well
informed about the gazettes
and about events in China.
And Osterhammel writes about this aspect
around mid 18th century.
The public in France, in Germany,
was better informed about China
than about many other countries
in the Europe's periphery.
And I find that a quite
important statement.
But yeah, you need
someone like Osterhammel,
who has more or less read everything,
don't make such a statement.
But what is even more important
is that Osterhammel
makes a clear, let's say,
distinction between the
pre-1800 and post-1800
way in which Europe speaks about the East.
So he speaks about an
inclusive Eurocentrism...
An exclusive Eurocentrism.
And in the first period,
what you have is that
quite a number of authors
make an attempt to let the East,
in this case, China, speak on the basis
of their own voices or texts.
And you see that already in
Du Halde and in other texts.
This... They really make it explicit.
They say, "We present translations."
Of course, translations are
always an interpretation.
But "We present the translation
because that's the best way
how you can understand China."
And it's very few interpretations.
So modern scholarship will focus morely
on the misinterpretation
of China by the scholars,
whereas maybe we have
to rediscover everything
that was already translated at that time.
So this was the distribution.
So we notice here that,
in fact, the information
that was, after all, relatively limited.
The three letters of Contancin
had a much wider distribution
in all kind of ways in Europe
so that Europe was
informed about gazettes.
But now what happened in
the interconnected history
and how did enlightenment thinkers...
Well, react or use or discuss the gazette.
And we start with Voltaire.
And here you see a quote
from a text that is entitled,
"Gazette" in a dictionary.
And that's in the famous
"Encylopedie ov Dictionnaire
(speaks French)."
"Encyclopedie ov Dictionnaire
Raisonne Des Sciences.
Des Art Et Des Metiers,"
and that is the famous
enlightenment dictionary,
"Encyclopedie."
In which anyone working on
enlightenment uses that.
One of the basic text in which
all the ideas were integrated.
And Voltaire writes the text on gazette,
in which he explains that the gazette
was invented in Venice at the
end of the 16th century...
Or the beginning of the 17th century,
and that it is called
gazette because of gazzetta,
which was a coin in Venice.
And you had to pay that coin to have
your one or two pages or
whatever of your newspaper.
And then, he adds, "Such
journals have been established
in China from time immemorial,
and the gazette of the
empire is printed there
every day by order of the court."
And you see immediately it
makes the link to China,
and it's not very clear what
is meant by time immemorial.
But at least it's a long time, that it...
Much longer than it happened in Europe.
He had some other commentaries.
I'll come back on that.
But the interpretation is quite difficult
of these other sentences.
Now, the next question is then...
Voltaire makes reference to it,
but did he actually read
the letters by Contancin?
And there we have a very nice proof,
because after Voltaire's death,
this whole library moved to
St. Petersburg by Catherine.
And in the 1960-70s,
when it was not easy to
do research in Russia,
at least interpretive research,
you had Russian researchers
going through all the volumes
and printing down all
the annotations by...
By Voltaire through the volumes.
And so I could check, and indeed,
he has several annotations in the letters
concerning the gazettes.
And then you find them also in my book.
You have the paper slips, the references.
And this is what I mentioned earlier.
And so here, Voltaire write...
Or this is the case of this Mr. Chiyeou,
which he discusses in one of his books.
So we know that he
actually read the gazettes.
He refers to it, in the gazettes,
in his most famous book,
"Essai sur les moeurs et
l'esprit des nations,"
which is a very, very important
book in terms of history,
because it's the text that
puts China first in history.
And it was a major revolution,
because it's not a biblical text,
it's not ancient Middle East or so.
It's China that is the
most ancient country.
And in it,
he writes then at, "The
journal of the Chinese empire,
the most authentic and useful
newspaper in the world,
since it contains the details
of all the public needs,
resources, and interest of
all the orders of the State."
So he writes some other things,
but that's most important.
Now besides the fact that
he mentions the gazette
and that he admires the gazette,
he also uses the information included
in the text by Contancin and also
"Description... de la Chine"
to discover his own idea
of an ideal government.
So for him, "The new emperor Yontching
surpassed his father in the love
of laws and public good."
These are all key notions,
the love of laws, that enters
in the French discussions,
and the public good.
And "No emperor encouraged
agriculture more."
This is the physiocrat,
will promoted the development
of agriculture for economy.
So he admires the role of the emperor.
There is no, in his eyes,
there is no evidence of a
despotic or arbitrary government.
It is a monarch,
will governs relying on
subordinated administrative boards.
And the officials were
selected through exams.
That was, yeah, something...
The Europeans were fascinated
by the Chinese examination system.
Which of course did not exist in France
or in Germany or in England.
And he also states that it's a lay state
based on justice and merit,
in which virtue is
independent from religion.
That is one of his major statement
"in which personal
value was more important
than hereditary privileges."
As was the case in France.
So this is a first approach.
Quite positive narrative
about the text that he finds,
and proclaiming how government should be,
and how France can take
inspiration from the Chinese case.
Not all the enlightenment
thinkers had the same opinion.
Montesquieu.
Here we can also prove that he read text
about the gazette,
namely is annotations in
"Description... de la Chine."
And he has a different opinion,
because according to him,
it is a despotic state.
It is a state with arbitrary power.
And what is one of his arguments?
He writes, "The author," namely Contancin,
"praises the gazette of painting...
Of Peking printed every day.
Nothing is put in it that has not
been presented to the Emperor."
We have seen the sentences.
"Two writers were punished with death
by putting false circumstances.
The judgment of the tribunal
was founded on the fact
that they had disrespected the Emperor,
which is a capital crime."
And then comes the
sentence by Montesquieu,
"Nothing is so dangerous
as these vague laws,
the disrespect is an arbitrary thing."
So he will interpret
descendants and he say,
"Yeah, that's a very nice example
of something that is very arbitrary.
Who is deciding on whether this is
not founded on facts or not?"
And so he... His classification of China
is a despotic state.
Quesnay is an physiocrat,
and he has a text
on "Despotisme de la Chine."
But we will see that his
interpretation as is...
Of despotism is different
from the one of Montesquieu.
Because for him,
"China is a country governed
by legitimate despots.
This is not a barbarian government.
Its fundamental Constitution was entirely
independent from the emperor."
So he explicitly makes
reference to the gazette.
It is a daily historical instruction.
And we find, again, the
case of the two writers.
In his eyes, "The law in China permits
the practice of
remonstration of the emperor.
There is perhaps no
country where the sovereign
can be remonstrated with
more liberty than in China."
So that's the interpretation by Quesnay.
The final case.
Now, these were three
enlightenment thinkers,
but at the same time,
we have another very interesting case.
Namely the first
Freedom of Press and
Freedom of Writing Act
in the whole of Europe,
which was voted in the
Swedish Parliament in 1766.
Now, Lena Rydholm,
and I could quote the
text also in my own book,
has shown in detail how the
two members of parliament
during several years
promoted this press act.
And finally, it was approved.
What was one of their sources
was "Description... de la Chine"
and the reference to the gazette.
She writes, "the freedom
of writing, of the press,"
and you can see that in the text.
"And the information had been in existence
in China since ancient times,
and had contributed substantially
to the wealth and stability of China."
In other words, in Europe, one said,
"We need a Freedom of Press Act,
and our big example is China."
Because there, since long
times, the freedom of press
has contributed to wealth and stability.
So to summarize this
part on the reception,
"Enlightenment thinkers based
themself on the information
from the gazettes."
And they developed their own ideas on it.
We have seen Voltaire and Quesnay.
Of course, I'm very fast
in the presentation.
These are general
presentations in the text.
Of course, it's much more subtle.
It's quite positive.
Montesquieu is negative.
And the two Swedish members of parliament
used it to promote the
freedom of the Press.
Osterhammel, another quotation
I like that he mentions,
"The objection that China was idealized
in "Sinophile" texts,
which drew the information mainly from
'Description... de la
Chine,' may be correct,
but misses the point."
Because first, "This Chinese bureaucracy
in the first half of the 18th century
was indeed perhaps the best
functioning in the world.
And its idealization was
an extrapolation from,
yeah, a certain reality."
Because Europe, even until today,
does not have such a system.
And second, "Reports
from the Middle Kingdom
gave European theorists
the first opportunity
to come to grips in a detailed way
with the problems of
administration and governance."
And you see how it functioned here.
So here, they are no longer
investigating the gazette.
They are not using it as a means
to understand why there is a gazette.
But the gazette is kind of
mirror, eh, that they use.
I would say not in the first
place to understand China,
but to develop their own ideas.
That's the interaction
that happened at that time.
And for us, or let's say for this topic,
what is interesting is
that this all happened
by the fact that there
were some missionaries
who decided that maybe this information
is important to translate
and send to Europe.
They never foresaw what
happened with this information.
Now, very briefly,
just to give a taste of what still
can be read in the book
is the Qianlong period.
There you have a major source,
"Memoires concernant
L'Histoire, Les Sciences,
Les Art, Les Moeurs, Les
Usages, Des Chinois."
15 volumes, and then two volumes
after the French Revolution
about 30 years later...
20 years later.
Very impressive text with
plenty of translations.
And this was the result of an interaction,
or an initiative, by Henri Bertin,
who was the counselor of the French King.
And who was, for 30 years,
in correspondence with
missionaries in Beijing.
And I mention here Amiot
and also Bourgeois.
We come back on him.
You have the picture of Amiot.
And we should not forget,
that's very important to underscore,
that all these missionaries
work together with Chinese.
This was always interaction,
a collaboration.
And in the case of Amiot, we
know the name of this Chinese.
And when he died,
it was kind of biography
and commemoration of him.
Also in the remark (speaks French)
What is also important
is that in the 1760s?
Yeah, 1760s, there were
at least two Chinese
who spent, I think, eight or
nine years in France, in Paris.
They entered Jesuit society there,
but then the Jesuits were abolished,
but they remained priests.
And when they returned, or
wanted to return, to China,
Bertin told them, "Well
I pay you for one year
to travel around in
France and to go and visit
factories for porcelain and for goblin,"
and so on and so on.
"And to discover the economy
and the cultural aspect in France.
And then when you go back to China,
you report about the same
topics back to Europe."
And so these people, these two Chinese,
they have also plenty of text in French.
in the (speaks French).
Now in it, you have
also a few hundred pages
only on the gazette.
And I select this one,
because there is three reference
to Sie-kou-tfiuen-chou.
So in 19... In 1779, we
have extensive reports
on the existence of the (speaks French).
So... And details the description of it.
And the...
(speaks Mandarin) that I showed before.
Are the original because
at a certain moment...
"I will send you a few copies."
And so that's why we have them in Paris.
And you have the detailed discussions
on the Qianlong emperor,
correcting or punishing some of his sons
because they made mistakes
in the transcription.
Because the emperor
regularly called some volumes
that were transcribed
of the (speaks French).
And then, he tried to find some mistakes,
and then he sent it back and he said,
"Well, here.
And there is a whole system of punishment
for every character
that you wrote wrongly."
Now, what happened with this,
we have also the notes by Bertin.
He was in regular contact
with the French king.
And here you have the quote...
I have to see it here.
(speaks French)
He has read, and that's
a passage that refers
also to the "Siku quanshu."
So we know that the
French king was informed
about the "Siku quanshu."
but what is even more is that Bertin
wanted to acquire a copy
of the "Siku quanshu."
So here he writes to China,
"This collection would
be a superb presence
to make to our Europe
which could thus enjoy
all the Chinese literature.
Please let me know if it would
be impossible to acquire it,
transmitted and packaged
at Canton, for example,
by making some gifts of
price to the Emperor,
which may be agreeable to him,
for example, tapestries,
goblins, mirrors."
So it's a very nice case how an advisor
to the French King in the 18th century
informed about this major
book project in China.
And even though it did not
know one character of Chinese,
wanted to acquire it.
Where are the times?
Where in Europe today?
There is a president or
king who gets the advice.
"Please, can we have a Chinese database
because that's so important.
We are very far from that times."
Just to finish with this here.
Bertin was also in contact with others,
like, for instance, Francois Bourgeois.
And Francois Bourgeois said,
"Well I will explain
you what is a gazette.
I will translate you
three months of gazette."
And so you have a whole manuscript
with translation of
nearly two or three months
of the gazette from the
beginning to the end.
It only leaves out the name list
of all the people who were appointed.
You can find that in the (speaks French).
It was not published.
But again, it shows how much information
about the gazette that was sent to Europe.
And in it you find all kind
of interesting information
among others about this
Lin Shuangwen rebellion
in Taiwan that took place.
And you have a whole discussion
because Francois Bourgeois will say,
"Yes, but they are saying that the...
That's the information by
the military officials,
but in fact we have other information."
And so that's an interesting case
of distribution of
information.
I come to a conclusion.
So I wanted, on the basis of the gazette,
which really started, as I
mentioned in the beginning,
as a kind of mistake because that was not
my intention to spend three
years on the the gazettes.
But... And when people ask
me, "What are you doing?"
I say, "I'm reading the gazette."
So first, I hope to have shown you
that by looking at this outside, again,
it's not the only way to write history.
That also this European gazette's sources
can expand the knowledge
about what was the gazette
in the 18th century.
And that this is also a nice case
of this interconnected history.
Not only by the fact that
they write about the gazette,
how they used the gazette as Europeans,
but also how it circulated in Europe.
And also was an inspiration
for a number of people
for development of their own ideas.
Not only about China,
but mainly about political
ideas for Europe.
So we can conclude that
already in the 18th century,
the Chinese gazette, yeah,
joined, in one way or
another, global public.
I thank you for your attention.
(audience applauding)
- (speaks softly) questions now.
- [Student] Thank you very much for the
very informative presentation.
My question is, during the
course of your research,
did you happen to...
Could you say more about
the printing process,
because the locus of my
inquiries, based on this premise,
that if there was a freedom oppressed,
then were there any
private presses that exist
during that time period? Thank you.
- Well, I would not join completely
the freedom of press
in the sense that what is said there
about the freedom of press
and the circulation of,
let's say, of information.
As you can see what I was
talking about is the gazette,
which is, to a large extent,
an official document.
And you have the, let's say,
the decisions that are
taken in the palace.
On the basis of this decision,
they make a selection of
what would be made public
and for different reasons,
because they think that the...
It's important that the decision is known,
but also that it's true
as a kind of instruction,
because it can have
precedent in decision making.
And then, this was copied,
and then it was printed.
And then in terms of printing technique,
these were mobile characters.
And for some, there is a whole discussion.
Was it mobile characters in
wood or the (speaks Mandarin)
For some scholars, this was in wax.
In wax where you can carve quicker.
But then it's also a block.
And then, this was sent to the provinces.
And there, again, they were republished,
or redistributed.
And sometimes also by
hundred... Let's say hundred.
So that is the system of this gazette.
So this is not,
I would say completely
a freedom of the press.
What we understand by
freedom of the press.
On the other hand,
you had, in China, the
publications of books.
And there was, unlike in Europe,
there was no pre-printing censorship.
In Europe, certainly in the
17th century, even later on,
you wanted to publish a book,
you needed the permission of the church
and of the state and... Or of vote.
And you see that in all the
text that it has mentioned.
You have nothing really
similar to that in China.
Of course there could be
post-printing prohibition
of the text.
So these are, in fact, different matters.
But I quoted that because they...
On the basis of the gazette,
whether what they write about
the gazette is true or false,
but this gave an inspiration
to develop an own idea.
That's what we see what
happens with this knowledge.
And that can be interpret
in different ways.
We can say, "Well they
just fantasize about China,
or they have seen all files."
Or you can also say,
what I sometimes say is,
"Yeah, but look how this
creates new knowledge
that is, to a certain extent, disconnected
from the original meaning."
But that happens with so many
of the things that we invent
or write, that this kind
of circulation happens.
- [Student] Well thanks
for that, Nicholas.
That was really great.
And I laughed seeing the Voltaire quote
where he talks about how everyone thinks
the gazette is free and also true.
Because in the 1620s,
no Chinese reader or a missionary reader
really trusted the gazettes-
- Yeah.
- [Student] Because it was full of
pre-imperial review material.
- Yeah.
- [Student] Which gets to the point
that this is a very dynamic genre
that by the Yeongjong reign is also
perfectly suited to now
re-representing the state
as a form of sort of auto propaganda,
even as the contents are true
and useful to governance.
And so my question for
you is to think about
what the actual function of the gazette
is for European readers?
When the producer sees this as a tool
that also produces propaganda,
whereas in Europe, they're
actually reflecting back
that propaganda almost perfectly.
So how should we understand early modern
global power relations if
we, in this broader context,
think about the ways
Europeans were consuming
Chinese propaganda and the
Chinese vision of itself,
which we've retrospectively
called Sinophilia,
when in fact that's just
the way Chinese texts
talk about themselves too?
- Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, you have a very
interesting and broad question.
So first, under the Yeongjong...
And that's why I think
Perroni is interesting,
because he's a bit more critical.
Because he would say and
give very concrete examples.
There is a flood
somewhere, and he will say,
"Yeah, that is reported by the officials,
but that does not represent
the reality." Yeah?
So you see the conflict that is there,
that this is an interpretation,
and that this is not just...
Or let's say that it is
propaganda by the state,
but you have Perroni's more
articulated view on it.
Unfortunately, it was not Perroni's text
that were published.
And so what was published is
Contoncin's vision.
And indeed, there you have the...
Criticism that the
missionaries give two words,
the newspapers in Europe,
and that then they contrast with China
where everything seems to be beautiful,
because finally you have
something that is official
in which they trust.
And that can be used for instruction
information of officials.
And the way in which the people,
let's say, thinkers reacted on that.
There you have again, a
wide variety of reactions.
So, but it's, in a certain way,
it's suited some of the
opinions in Europe also.
- [Student] Thank you. Sorry.
The Hume is an occasion for
us to think about the past
and the history of Sinology.
And listening to you speak,
I was of course thinking
about Jonathan Spence
and how much he would've
enjoyed your lecture.
I do have one question for you,
which is not knowing anything
at all about the gazette.
Your...
You've found all this
information in the 18th century.
Does that information change
our overall view of the gazette?
Going through to the 19th century?
- [Nicolas] I do not
really dare to say too much
because in the end, yeah, I was...
I didn't want to write a book
on the gazette as a whole.
And you have, for instance,
the book by (indistinct) who
has the much broader view.
So I didn't want to enter completely
into that kind of discussion,
but there are certainly
differences with the 19th century.
Because the circulation of the
gazette is much more widely.
This is one of the aspects.
But also, yeah, what was the circulation
in the 17th century also?
We were discussing that earlier.
Yeah we know relatively little
about the (speaks Mandarin)
But when I look at the
missionary sources, yeah,
you are quite...
Convinced that they really
used these kind of sources.
Because when they write and they...
Every year they write an annual letter.
And they write first, always
in the beginning of the letter,
a state of the art of the country.
And then, they have...
And then Christianity.
And then they have the provinces
and something about the province,
and then Christianity in the province.
Now, when you look at
all this information,
you simply wonder where did they got it?
This was not, let's say,
was not oral information.
It's so detailed that
it must have been based
on these sources.
But they were also digested
because they make a kind of synthesis.
But yeah, the structure...
At least the structure
of the gazette changes,
to a certain extent,
also in the 19th century.
And you see some differences
in the structure of it.
But I didn't want to get involved too much
in the 19th century because
that's not my field.
Yeah, thank you for your question. Yeah.
- [Student] Thank you very
much. I really loved this talk.
I just learned a lot. It was so much fun.
So I know very little about this period,
but I do know that this wasn't the only...
These weren't the only
translations that were happening
in this period. Right?
And it might even be fair to say that
the first wave of
translations of Chinese texts
into Europe were translations
of the Chinese classics,
of the four books and things like that
maybe just a little bit
earlier in this period.
So I'm wondering, could
you take a step back
and just reflect on the
place of these translations
of gazettes compared within this larger
universe of translations of Chinese texts?
Are there certain kinds of audiences
that are more focused on the gazettes?
Are there other kinds of audiences
that are more focused on,
let's call it Confucius, stuff?
Because that is maybe the
first wave of translations.
Is there a competition in Europe
to sort of to decide, you know,
which sorts of texts are gonna determine
really the image of China?
Who are the players or their audiences
and sub audiences?
Like, what is the larger scene,
and how does this talk fit
into that... Our sense of...
- Yep, so first we can say
that the translations...
Translations started
relatively late, because...
Yeah, but a few exceptions.
But you have the Confucius
philosophers, which is...
So that's seven... 1689.
Yeah, Matteo Ricci
arrived in China in 1582.
So that's about 100 years later.
So in which they make...
And that's thanks to
the "exile" in Canton.
They are together,
and they really make a translation
of these basic classics.
Now this...
The time, let's say shift,
is 1688,
because (indistinct) comes back to Europe,
who edited the (speaks French)
And he goes to Paris,
and he meets the people
of the (speaks French)
And there this academicians say,
"We need more information about China."
And they have this enormous
list of what they want to know.
What about history?
What about the origin of the characters?
What about zoology, botany,
all these questions.
And so then, the French
missionaries will go to China.
They are not sent by Rome,
not through Portugal,
but from France.
And they go to China.
And there starts, yeah...
This is shift from the
Renaissance to more, yeah,
pre-modernity scholars.
And in the beginning, they
are active missionaries,
and they start to do some translations.
But then in 1724, basically
you have an expulsion,
and they are confined in Beijing.
And they will be less...
It will be less possible to produce,
like Ricci and all these
people, text in Chinese.
And there you see a shift also through
the better communication,
because the travel of
documents and so is less long
where there is this, yeah,
still under (speaks French)
Petersburg, Beijing, and in Paris.
And they correspond,
and they start to discuss chronology...
Or they continue to discuss chronology
and botany and so on and so on.
And so from that time onwards,
you have a kind of systematic attempt
to solve all the questions
that they got there.
And that is a shift,
because the efforts of these
missionaries and translations
will be more devoted to
translating Chinese text
to Europe than European text to Chinese.
And was there... Was
that adapted to republic?
That was partly adapted to republic,
but in the first place of academicians.
So they were in contact
some with astronomy
and the chronology, but yeah.
(speaks French) that is botany and zoology
and all these kind of texts.
And then, you have the major
efforts by Du Halde, in fact,
who says, "Yes, send me...
I don't have anything
about moral philosophy."
And then, he has a text about
moral philosophy and so on.
So it becomes a major enterprise,
which is still striking
because if you simply look at the...
We have it on our database also.
All the text that were translated.
Many of these text are still...
We don't have a modern English, French,
German, or whatever
translation of all these texts,
which are original Chinese text
by very well-known authors,
but also by rather unknown authors.
Recently, you have in this
"Description... de la Chine."
You have the book by (speaks French)
who identified nearly all the text.
There were five left,
three were then identified
in the last few years.
And I discovered now the last
two text on moral philosophy.
And these are Chinese (speaks Mandarin),
but by authors that we have never heard.
And what is interesting is that then
they illuminate the circulation
of certain text in China,
because they were translated
and used by missionaries.
Because how did it work?
It's relatively easy.
You want to know something
about moral philosophy,
you ask a Chinese scholar,
"What do you... What is a good book?"
And he says, "So in my
desk, I have this book here.
You should translate this."
And that's how it work. Yeah.
- [Student] Thank you.
As an anthropologist, I am
not tuned to changes in time.
So I know I, you know,
I would like to ask a question
that's quite different from
my historian colleagues.
I just want... You
know, your idea of China
as a concept intrigues me.
You know, I kind of like to have you
to see if you can clarify your idea
of how you define China
in that historical context
and the missionary's perception of China.
And then of course, the European scholars'
concept of China and how they differ.
'Cause I was also noticing that
quite a bit of the activities
were happening in Canton.
At least, you know, in the
period you're treating.
And I just wonder how
these people's conception
of the country might be shaped
by very regional context
that they found themselves in.
So I just want to get
a sense of this kind of
regional ethnic, you know...
You know, ecologically even,
diversity of this entity we call China,
and how that affects the way that we would
think about the gazettes and
then also their translations.
- Yeah, thank you very much.
It's also a very large question.
I happened to write even articles
about the concept of China in
all these missionary texts.
But to be very brief, it is not China.
It is Ming or it is Ching,
and they adopt, in the first place,
the auto definition by China.
Because when you look at
Chinese maps of the time,
they will never write China.
Because if you have no authority...
As a Belgium, if you
only have a Belgium map,
you don't have to put Belgium.
Because you only put Belgium
when you have other countries around.
What they will write is "Ming."
Ming is a Ming Dynasty
because your authority
is a former dynasty.
And there it is Ching.
Now the Ching is not
only what we call China
(speaks Mandarin)
it's also the Manchus.
So in these texts...
Well I didn't develop it, but in my book,
I have a few pages on that.
Because for the missionaries,
when they communicate with the emperor,
most often this is a
Manchu and not in Chinese.
They use Manchu sources also.
They even refer to some
possible Manchu gazettes. And...
So that's one of the differentiations,
ethnic differentiations, because yeah,
these are the...
The emperors, but the emperors are emperor
of the Hun and the Mongols
and of the Tibetans
and the Chinese and
the Manchus. So it's...
There is already this
kind of "ethnic," if...
We have to be prudent with all these words
transforming at that time.
And then... But that's less true for
the information I have about, let's say,
Amyu time.
The missionaries are all only in Beijing.
And that's, I would say, the direct link,
because that's two kilometers
further it's produced,
and you have your newspaper.
In Canton, it's different
because they get also
information from the provinces.
So the provincial newspapers,
that's on the country period.
There is a whole, yeah,
the best information about
the Tangshan earthquake.
It's by the missionaries and
not by the Chinese sources.
And they based themself on the information
from the different regions.
So these are kind of intercessors
where I would say, yeah, I really agree
in this differentiation.
But yeah, when you give a presentation,
you cannot nuance every term.
So yeah.
- [Host] Thank you very much.
We are continuing the conversation
upstairs in a reception,
so feel free to come and ask
any further questions upstairs
over a drink and something to eat.
But I did want to thank
very much our speaker today
for that really fascinating
and interesting talk.
I forgot in my introduction to point out
how meticulous his scholarship is
and what a range it covers.
But we've seen that today in abundance.
So thank you very much.
I think it's given everybody something.
Just the discussions and our
thoughts about modern China
and the relationships between
the French singularity
and China, for example.
Or the fact that everyone was
better informed about China
in the mid 18th century are fascinating
for us to think about
contemporary politics.
So thank you very much
for such a superb talk.
(audience applauding)
(soothing music)